nothing's more precious than speech and
the right to free speech and the right
to share information and receive
information freely I'm very
uncomfortable with the idea of kind of
corporatizing what is fundamentally a
human right by exporting that
responsibility to foreign companies
where it gets really controversial of
course is where the government was
seeking to go even further and create
this whole notion of legal but harmful
Beach that was also deserving of
censorship we did actually win the
campaign against restrictions around
this extraordinary category made of
category of speech in relation to adults
so the idea was that the companies would
have to make up rules around harmful
speech that's completely lawful and then
enforce those basically to censor lawful
speech